PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Hey, everyone.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and you are watching
"Deconstructing Chatbots."
In today's episode, we will
explore entities further.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
From the second
and third episodes,
you might remember that entities
are Dialogflow's mechanism
for identifying and extracting
useful data from user's input.
If you've not checked
out the episode
on "Getting Started
with Dialogflow,"
please do so for more context.
Just scroll up to the
second episode on the right,
or click in the link
and description below.
There are three types of
entities-- system entities,
developer entities,
and session entities.
Now you might remember from our
appointment scheduler chatbot
when we said need an appointment
for 4:00 PM tomorrow,
the date and time
were automatically
extracted as system
entities date and time.
It was all automatic.
As you saw, system
entities allow
agents to extract information
about a wide range of concepts
without any additional
configuration.
Data like address, emails,
currency, phone numbers
are some of the common
examples of system entities.
Now so far, we have been
addressing our appointment
scheduler in a generic manner.
Let's say our
scheduler is for DMV.
We click on Entities
and create a new entity.
Let's call this
Appointment Type.
Let's think about the types
of services DMV offers.
Most people go to the DMV
for a drivers license,
maybe vehicle registration,
also driving tests.
So in our scenario, let's stick
to the two main services--
drivers license and
vehicle registration
are obviously the
two main ones that I
can think of that DMV offers.
So let's create those
two as entities.
You can add more rows with
more services as entity types.
Additionally, you
can check the box
to add more entities
automatically.
When an entity is not
available in the entity list,
Dialogflow identifies that
this is an entity based
on other training phrases
and adds that new entity
automatically to the list.
You can also upload or
download entities in bulk
in CSV or JSON format.
Now let's add more intents to
accommodate the appointment
type entity in our inputs.
When you add Set an Appointment
for Driver's License for 3:00
PM tomorrow, driver's license is
identified as developer entity
that we just set up, while
time and date are obviously
system entities.
Add a few more training
phrases like these.
Now remember slot filling
from episode three
when we built our
appointment scheduler?
To book an accurate
appointment, we
needed to make appointment
type a required field
just like time and date.
Let's define the right prompt
for when a user does not
provide us the appointment type.
Now while we are at it,
let's modify our response
to include the appointment type
along with the date and time
to make it look more complete.
When done, don't forget
to save your changes.
And then, let's test our updates
now with some sample inputs.
The first example,
let's say, user only
gives us the appointment type.
Well, slot filling kicks in and
asks for the time and the date
when they want to come in.
All looks good.
We get the
appointment scheduled.
In the second example,
let's say, a user says,
I need an appointment
for 4:00 PM tomorrow
without providing us
the appointment type.
Again, our slot filling
kicks in and prompts the user
to provide us the
service information.
They say driver's
license, and we
provide them a response with
their appointment confirmation.
In our third and last
example, let's say
the user gave us
all three things
we needed in just one shot--
set an appointment for vehicle
registration at
2:00 PM tomorrow.
Our bot has everything
it needs, so it
sends a confirmation response
back to the user right away.
Now the third type of
entity is session entity.
These are defined at
session ID level, which
allows for a specific
entity to be tied
to a user and their session.
Let's take an example to
understand this better.
Our agent had appointment
type as entity,
which includes drivers
license and vehicle
registration at this point.
That entity could be
updated to include a state
ID or a motorcycle
test depending
on the information your
agent collects from the user
during the conversation.
The updated session entity will
have state ID or motorcycle
test entry for rest of the
conversation with your user.
Well, try this out
on your own, and let
me know how it goes
in the comments below.
Remember, you will
create, manage, and update
session entities using the API.
That was a lot, so
let's summarize.
Today, we looked at the
three types of entities--
system entity, developer
entity, and session entities.
Then, we went hands
on and learned
how to set up these entities
in our appointment scheduler
chatbot.
Don't miss the next episode
of "Deconstructing Chatbots"
because we are going to
integrate our appointment
scheduler with Twilio
Messaging Service.
[MUSIC PLAYING]